this is monster buddies how sad
so Steven finds out that you can
basically pull out these kind of plastic
bubbles and release a monster and then
you can train this monster and then
maybe he can help you on your adventures
maybe defeat other monsters and oh my
god Steven great a pokemons ha ha ha ha
I think was it she I'm not sure I think
he called it she was but I'm not even
sure he knew oh but no I just somewhere
in the middle of it that was like hey
wait a sec a lips are like a pokeball
yeah um I mean yeah Johnny prequel to
pokey baby needs the origin story goes
be amazing and a left out it'd be an
amazing letdown um I really really like
this one uh well we're finally getting
business been bothering me I'm just like
but what is with all the indiscriminate
killing of these mommy show now they are
going somewhere and they're like I get
Kylie poking they are going somewhere
but like whatever and then the reveal at
the end just like well your mom thought
that perhaps you could trade monsters
but yeah she sucked at it that was like
but we don't get your powers you'll be
better that was like maybe the three of
you could try is ma ha ha ha ha
I'm mrs. wave we're gonna be like
killing things is fun but I I kind of
like that Bell see I like that a half
and a half at the end we're cuz Steven
possibilities but Terra is the Luke
Skywalker here he will find another way
why a Jedi just want him to kill Veit it
buddy they will find the middle pet it's
very obvious those three are constantly
busy trying to stop these things to
learn how to kill them and stuff you
know they're not trained to figure out
how to really you know love or toxic
obvious these three are matt irres um
and but even then you know garnet says
you know alright I trust you Steve and
I'll give you a chance maybe because
Rose did than the past two but I mean
chances are they've been trained to
learn how to stop these things and they
don't technically kill um I mean they
they put them in the the jewel or
whatever but you could argue that's even
worse we don't know what it's like to be
the champ I did I know I was like I was
like looks pouring yeah but me mom I can
sleep or something we don't know that's
the kid show element but Stephen can
bubble now and we found that out it yeah
yeah no the big reveal is that that's
what road to me that was the big reveal
that that's what Rose was trying to do
but on top of that I'm guessing just
gonna go on with a chips gonna fact that
they can be trained at all is also a big
with what a happened in this one
yeah but it also had that really nice
like they're they're sort of an
interesting message that was not an easy
message no baby you shouldn't
indiscriminately kill things position
but nobody charge that hurt to when it
will like when the the centipede puppy
basically went nuts and they're like
what card it just drop kicks it Punk
you're like whipping up the legs over
it's not like holy you can't blame
them I mean this thing is destroying the
place and me attacking a control and
they don't know why I mean I probably my
guess is not oh I was I was kind of
waiting that I was kind of waiting for
Steven to go all elfin lead on them and
just like blow the whole room up no see
you time they're getting the probably an
openly there is like oh come on Stacy to
me it totally makes sense I mean they're
trying to do it where it's like hey they
don't want to kill it but they want make
sure it's not gonna hurt anyone else I
don't want to go and if this did you see
them whippin and drop okay this thing
spits acid okay it could be and kill you
like this big though if this was a giant
monster the day and you'd have one drop
of a sound your head I have okay
I I have a history and what ya know if
that's how it got that's it so it gives
you a really Bad's it and they should
not risk those this but no it's this
thinking spits destroying the room I
mean they didn't kill it but yeah they
have to like stop it you know I mean
guys one here no not good
animal abuse and you technically can't
kill it anyway cuz it turns it to a gym
so ya know I don't know that was like
watching animal abuse it was bugging me
and I'm to sign up but you're supposed
to be uncomfortable too because it
doesn't know any better so in the fact
that they made it sound kind of like a
beaten puppy it's like I want to yeah it
was like dude err interesting thing too
it starts off she knows what opens up
it's a person first yeah and then it
turns into the giant centipede Oh thing
and then to this tiny thing so it's like
maybe they're former champ yeah I don't
know could be I mean I I don't know what
Christ help us if this goes on Madoka
Magica honest you don't know about me
know what I do
Oh God um that would that would be dark
and an interesting twist no but I like I
thought was a good you know sort of me
it felt very bad man DME it's serious to
me like you know it's not always easy
lessons out there with happy endings and
stuff sometimes there's just sort of uh
sometimes you have to watch as your
three mother figures just abuse a poor
animal system monster thingy
this is so um yeah I think anything else
to say about this one no I'm just
horrified this is you just completely
condone their actions well you know what
my wife just got home so we can Duke it
out we can see if she thinks I'm a dog
killer wanna kill her
well okay there you go your huh I like
just a Maddog killer and I think we can
leave on that please send all emails to
Doug Walker at channel some by tani